how come you don't laugh
n Ain you got something to make you just
[Music]
smile my sister and I ain't seen her in
years you know if you ain't going to
laugh you need to sell your footy
[Music]
bone I was married to a man I didn't
love whatever I say
[Music]
go and he took my sister away from me
even if we have to part you and me us
have one
heart how come you so nice don't know
maybe you too
nice you seem like trouble I come here
out of
respect but it's Dam ain't nothing to
get that show ain't nothing to
[Music]
get now that I got your
attention here's
[Music]
what drink
something P the button there going to be
some changes
made you got to stand up
I know my sister somewhere in the
world someday we're going to meet
again keep your head held high just like
mom taught us it's time i' be free from
you and then turn your creation I died
before I let that happen good that's
just a g away present I've been
[Applause]
needing bab baby
[Music]
baby what are you got to do time for you
see the world P the
button sweet and loving
[Music]
God
com